somebody told me i'm the first person to
have resigned on instagram i mean you
knew yeah much more glamorous
hello and welcome to women with balls
where i katie balls speak to today's
trailblazers there are decades where
nothing happens and there are weeks
where decades happen
we might not be there yet but the past
two weeks have seen 52 ministerial
resignations go and spend some time with
my family needing a prime minister to
resign limbs the brakes and 11
candidates fight to replace him now
whittled down to two thank you all very
much able to keep up on today's episode
of women balls we are going to hit the
rewind button to the mass resonations
that meant a new prime minister and what
goes through your mind when you're one
of those ministers who ultimately
decides to make the jump
my guest today has served in government
since theresa may appointed her in 2017
as the parliamentary under secretary of
state for crime safeguarding and
vulnerability as a minister at the home
office she worked to deliver the
landmark domestic abuse act for a stint
as a minister for afghan resettlement
and the minister for prisons and
probation in september 2021. she spent
much of her time being described as a
rising star but on the 6th of july she
resigned from johnson's government
citing that values such as integrity
decency respect and professionalism have
become fractured under johnson's
leadership my guest today is victoria
atkins
victoria thank you for joining us today
you have been on this podcast once
before i have i what's the old saying
about you do katie balls on the way up
and katie ball's on the way down i don't
know that's absolutely not we're not
going for the weight down at the moment
but if we have to we're at the end no we
have pointed out recently i think that
um many have come here before greatness
yeah
john and scan then i think won a bafta
after appearing on this podcast and
there's trusses wrote to foreign
secretary after so that's just one to
bear in mind no pressure ahead of the
reshuffle of the next prime minister
now um victoria i mentioned that
introduction had herbie than politics in
westminster has been recently and i
wanted you to start with recent events
now you of course resigned from boris
johnson's government just a few weeks
ago
and i think for our listeners because so
much has been going on
it's it's easy to move past i think what
was clearly a seismic 48 hours
which uh began i think with how number
10 handled uh chris pincher and
complaints against him that at the time
the deputy chief whip he had to step
down for that role and then the
resignation of sadhu java then rishi
sunak then the next day yours was one of
several
so where to begin i wondered um at what
point this year did you start to
really question your position
as i said in my letter i i was very
concerned at the handling of the um
paterson events last year
you may recall that there was a report
that the house had uh delivered and um
on reading it it seemed to be pretty
clear-cut as to what was said to have
been said to have been done
and we were put in the position of
having to vote basically vote the report
down
and that was really difficult and
actually that's where collective
responsibility
really shone through because as
ministers you are bound by collective
responsibility you may
privately disagree and have your
discussions um but you are ultimately
bound by collective responsibility and
so lots of us were concerned we um
voiced those concerns privately but
nonetheless we absolutely honored the
fact that we had to abide by collective
responsibility obviously then that
uh was um uh that started to unravel
uh and then we went into partygate and
that was an incredibly difficult time
for everyone um
i think including actually boris because
uh
he was working under enormous pressure
everybody there was working under
enormous pressure of course they were
and yet these things
seem to have been going on and i think
um there was a real shift in in the
public mood as these allegations came to
light more and more
and then we had chris pincher and
the
allegations about him come to light and
uh for me and for a lot of other
colleagues i think we were very
concerned at how it was handled and then
on the monday
our colleague will quince was sent out
in the media round which is something we
all do you know
um and
it uh
it then the position changed after he
was sent out i actually had media that
day as well be a pre-record
and so i was a little bit sensitive
about that as well and then um
on the tuesday night uh completely out
of blue sag resigned russia resigned and
uh i think we all
just started reflecting on our own
positions there was absolutely no
agreement conspiracy plot whatever you
know to resign as a minister is a very
lonely long path
and we all felt that on the night before
it happened
and for those listeners who i suppose
are less familiar of how the system
works in terms of a morning round of
doing media um
is it the case that
i mean dinosaur will often tell you the
lines to take or give you a suggestion
and therefore through the series of
incidents you just outlined was it the
trust in what you're being told as the
case started to deteriorate well when
you're sent out on a media run it's
generally because you've got a policy to
announce so yeah in the course of all my
ministerial appointments i had really
really
um great policy announcements
announcements such as the domestic abuse
act and you go ready to talk about your
policy but of course issues of the day
are raised with you as well because any
journalist
doing their job properly will ask you
about other matters so
with the best one in the world you
cannot be no no single minister below
the prime minister can be the expert on
every single aspect of policy across
government we are specialists in our own
areas
and so you rely on the briefings for for
example me for me it would be i don't
know trade policy or something like that
you you you get those briefings you
absolutely accept them in good faith and
you know the people who work at number
10 are very bright very capable people
um but it
what was
what became more difficult with these
situations is that it wasn't about
policy
it became about
who knew what when etc and that's when
it became pretty difficult actually
um now you mentioned the point being
when sergeant javid and rishi sunak
resign so that is the
eve before the prime minister's question
so boris johnson was effectively
battling through saying he was going to
fight on but in the process just losing
junior ministers by you know by the hour
perhaps even more than that um so what
was it like then the night before was
that the point you started to think
maybe i am going to go i've actually but
you're right that there was so much that
happened in that 48 hours um it was
there was also of course lord mcdonald's
letter and he was a very senior civil
servant i'd never i'd never heard of him
i'd never met him i didn't you know know
him from adam um but he wrote this
letter and then did a an interview
setting out his understanding of a
particular situation and for any senior
civil servant to do that that's quite
unusual
um and so when after that we then had uh
as i say the ball began to be to roll i
i know for a fact that others were
contemplating and thinking about it very
very carefully that day
but um
there was no as i say no coordination
and in fact you can tell that from the i
think from the sort of the timing and
the range of people that sent their
letters in
um but it's it's
it was a very very difficult tuesday
night because i was doing a job i love a
job i believe in yeah we were doing
really great stuff uh tackling violence
against women and girls that sort of
thing
and so it's a big responsibility to
say actually i i need to step back from
this
um now when it came to writing that
resignation letter um i saw
your chil
you're organizing your school run yes um
but also drafting is that correct
because i do you know i've never thought
through how to how one goes about
resigning i've never resigned for
anything in my life and so the actual
mechanics of it
um
you sort of do your best and hope that
first of all you're dealing with people
with respect and dignity and doing it
properly and courteously but i'd i woke
up on the
must be the wednesday morning
and woke up quite early and i thought
actually i'm i'm gonna do it and then i
so i started drafting it um before the
school run eight o'clock is when we have
to leave the house and uh
started right drafting it and then went
got got my 10 year old ready for school
teeth brushed everything and then dashed
dashed off and did the school run and i
i remember standing in a coffee shop on
my way back thinking
gosh this is a bit this is a bit odd you
know
here i am studying this coffee shop i've
got half a resignation letter ready and
i've got to finish the rest when i get
get
uh back home and then i did finish it
and then um in of course in the uh
in a very good episode of the thick of
it of course when i then came to
printing it out the
internet wasn't working the printer
wasn't getting anyway we got there
um and does that mean you're sending it
to a machine that's just not exactly it
just wasn't but it's your
would
private
printer
about to merge when someone is going to
like find the thing before i've actually
said i'm doing it yeah and uh
just in
absolutely personal ipad etc but um
it's uh it's just one of those sort of
lighter moments in what was actually
pretty dark pretty upsetting morning but
um i got it i got it printed out and
then i thought right i want to um let my
secretary of state know and let the
chief whip know
so um i
uh managed to i put phone calls through
i managed to speak to one of them and
then um i sent it out and it's you know
that's a really
it's a really serious moment where you
press send
because ultimately the evening that
rishi sudan and sajid javid resigned it
felt as though it was a big blow to
boris johnson but they quickly filled
those roles and so you had nadim zahori
being chancellor michelle donald's
education secretary and all the
briefings coming out at number 10 was
look we can fill the positions we're
going to keep going this is a setback
but we can now actually have the
economic plan we want so in a way from
observing from parliament watching it
the death now was actually really just a
continuous flow of resignations the next
day of which you were one so did you
have people trying to say don't do this
getting in touch or not so much
no again i think
for someone to make that decision it's
it's their decision their decision alone
and look i totally totally respect
colleagues who
uh
you know made their decision to stay i
totally get that um but
you can't you couldn't possibly and
nobody tried
one couldn't put any pressure on another
colleague to do anything because
it is their decision it's it's their
career their livelihood their conscience
now i want to talk about the future of
the tory party but just before we do get
there um
it's interesting obviously hearing the
events how there were so many
distractions in the sense you no longer
felt so you could focus on your brief
because the level of number 10 scandals
that dominate even a positive news
announcement
but i wonder if also some of the
negative briefings from downing street
played a factor because um certainly in
the case of oliver darden you would have
a situation where
you know various figures and we never
quite know who the source behind
anonymous quotes are were ultimately
suggesting he might be sacked anyway as
party chairman and which then i think
given he was the first regular nation
after the double by-election um it
probably made his decision a bit easier
um had they not been there and certainly
i think after the confidence vote in
boris johnson your name sometimes
appeared among some of your colleagues
suggesting
you hadn't been pro boris johnson enough
publicly how did that feel
it felt pretty unfair actually because i
have been entirely loyal uh to this
administration and to
since i've been elected since 2015 i'm
i'm i am a loyalist uh i'm a
conservative through and through
and
i
absolutely believed in boris when
he was selected as our leader our prime
minister and then went on to win that
amazing election victory and delivered
brexit and then coped through covid that
extraordinary parent time
and i was
being sent out to do um to talk on
behalf of the government which i really
appreciated and i took very very
seriously uh and so it was a bit it's i
mean it's it's part of sadly it seems to
be part of politics but i'm not sure
it's terribly good for general morale i
wouldn't dream of speaking for others
but i'm not sure it's terribly good for
general morale i'll put it tactfully
like that yeah i suppose some people
listening to this podcast might say well
if it was really that bad why didn't you
resign sooner why resign when you know
already some people were already out
there i wanted what would you say to
them about it genuinely was an
escalation and uh it
again because
we're all incredibly committed as
ministers to our roles you know we work
very very hard in the background people
don't necessarily see it but
every minister will get their red box
every evening they get their weekend
boxes it's
it
some days my days were measured in
15-minute slots because i had so much
racing around to do between uh
commitments meetings parliamentary
businesses on so it's a real
it's a real
vocation not just a job
and i personally felt an enormous duty
not just to
the government but also to the people
we're trying to help you know victims of
crime uh particularly rape victims and
we're doing some really really positive
work
within the criminal justice system so
for me
i i needed to
i needed to be sure that it was the
right thing to do and it took time took
time to get there
now i wanted looking back on this now
we're speaking just after boris
johnson's final prime minister's
questions and
the entire tory party sat in the commons
chamber including yourself gave the
prime minister's standing ovation quite
right yeah
so
what do you think the problem was do you
think
boris johnson was dishonest or do you
think he was let down by the people
around him
gosh i don't know i suspect uh political
historians will be studying this um in
years to come uh i just i think he'd
done such an amazing job for us both
with the 2019 election and with brexit
and with the pandemic
um
but if you look at any prime ministerial
career
they come to an end and it's usually not
of a time or of a
a process of their choosing
and so i
i think that was the case here as well
and just just a two final ones for us i
want to talk about the future of the
party which is just one which is
we spoke about on your last podcast with
us which is a few years ago now because
uh you're once in the news for your own
conversation boris johnson
where you took him to task
or maybe that's you can tell me if i'm
phrasing it wrong but over he claimed in
an interview that he'd um that money
spent investigating historic cases of
child sex abuse as being spaffed off the
wall
and i just wanted do you think the prime
minister learnt from that experience
after that right so i've never confirmed
that you're being very very uh
cunning if i may say so uh but uh
reports at the time reports
uh
look
what i can say is um i genuinely was
uh
really blown away by his absolute
commitment to helping um victims of
sexual abuse as when he was prime
minister so
uh the the rape review the work that we
did through that he he absolutely
gave that his 100 personal um commitment
and was regularly being briefed on what
we're up to and you know he really
really did so uh
i i'm not i think he does take those
issues seriously
i really do i genuinely do and i think
um as i said i'm neither confirming nor
denying but uh
his record
over the last couple of years i think
actually stands alone and speaks for
herself sure and then
we're going to talk about the future
leader but just at a time when obviously
the candidates are being whittled down
there has been some backlash from
certain members in the tory grassroots
who
and i think some voters who probably
don't follow politics that closely and
are just wondering why the prime
minister is
no longer going to be prime minister and
i just wonder what you might say to them
and you know we are starting to see a
bit of a movement to say you know should
it be right the mps can oust a leader um
do you understand why there might be
some upset in the country i do but then
um
i remind myself that we live in a
parliamentary democracy so we did not
live in a presidential system uh the
conservative party led by boris and i
don't take that away you know at all but
the conservative party won the last
election
and the leader of the day um
any prime minister of the day if one
takes you know if we take a step out of
2022 and just think about it um in the
round uh the prime minister of the day
has to have the confidence of their
parliamentary party
and um i think the
the the
events of two weeks ago with ministers
resigning and so on that that
showed sadly that um the time had moved
on
and now we are talking during a
leadership contest and it's been a
bruising period so before we get to the
candidates what do you think the tory
party has to do now in order to kind of
deliver on its promises but also
potentially win a fifth term which
no party has done well first of all i
think it's amazing that we had such a
diverse list of candidates you know from
all across the board at the very
beginning those i think 11 candidates
they just they represent our country in
the 21st
21st century i'm so proud of
our party for doing that and uh the
you know we're now at the stage we're
just ahead of the announcement so we'll
find out the final two but uh we will
have
well the final three candidates two are
women and uh we have rishi so whoever
whatever the final two looks like and
obviously i hope rishi is in there but
it's going to be an incredibly um i
think incredibly modern offering to the
country something that labour has never
ever got within sniffing distance of
achieving and i think that it does show
that our
we're just very open to moving with
society if we don't move with society we
will
we will lose as a as an electoral party
and so i genuinely think that the ideas
we've heard are really exciting
and you're backing rishi sooner
um
do you worry in a sense that there is it
does seem to be a block you think rishi
soon acts responsible for bringing boris
johnson right we hear it
jeremy lincoln we hear it from satan
people you've served under boris johnson
here at anonymous briefings um do you
think rishi cena can really unite the
tory party yeah i do and i think i hope
that we're in a very uh
it's the white heat of an election a
leadership election at the moment and
and so yeah there will be conversations
briefings and so on but um if as i hope
rishi's in the final two and if as i
hope uh he secures the
leadership
then we will settle down and things will
fall into place and and whoever wins i
am absolutely determined to support them
you know it's an extraordinary thing to
put yourself forward for this role just
if you look at some of the scrutiny some
of the candidates have had and by the
way we've got an amazing three
candidates left by it but you know some
of the scrutiny stroke criticism they've
had
it it you know they're really being put
through their paces and so uh it is on
each and every one of us as members of
the party
uh to get behind the new leader in
september and really help them make it
work
um so i think you've probably already
answered this but that means i mean
risby we're speaking when it's liz trust
penny more than rishi soon act but if
any of those three were to become prime
minister
you will be happy to fully back them
service yeah i'd be absolutely delighted
because i think they're both look
they've got different strengths
and i
believe very firmly in rishi but look i
others my friends my colleagues believe
in
in the other two candidates well as well
and i would fully respect and support
them
and just i suppose looking at the brief
juvian if you just a few couple of final
questions i mean is there
is there anything that you're
particularly worried might not be
carried through by the next leader or
who you think that needs to make sure
there is continuity on
but from hearing some of the debates
so i think there will be there are some
areas of policy where uh
clearly the leaders the leadership
candidates will take different
approaches
and there is that sort of freedom if you
like to to do that in my own area of
expertise
the criminal justice system i'm very
much hoping indeed i i suspect they will
all and rishi indeed has already
committed to this we will of course
continue our work to improve uh justice
for victims we she's announced that
we're going to have a victims and
sentencing bill uh we're going to really
tackle uh gang grooming gangs and so on
so that's that is just
that's a moral imperative to continue
that work so i'm confident that other
people would want to continue as well as
for economic matters and so on they are
showing their difference in approaches
and i it will be for the membership to
decide
which approach they most prefer
and
just on your briefs so you're no longer
in this role but you were role as a
minister for afghan resettlement and i
just wanted as an is obviously one of
those things there's lots of media focus
at the time and lots please you know let
more people in and so forth
how do you think that there should be
more attention to it now it feels it's
almost dropped off i suppose the
public's gaze a bit but from your
experience of dealing with actually the
technicalities of you know housing these
people who come here um i just want to
you felt like there should be more focus
now or or if there is kind of still the
same level of enthusiasm amongst the
public as there was at the time well
crikey we if you think of the last year
we've moved from the pandemic
to afghanistan and then to ukraine and
so at each and every turn the public has
shown
their resilience but also their
enthusiasm to help
but inevitably if you have that sort of
if you like that train of events uh
running down the train tracks then
the media and others focus will move
away to what's happening at the moment i
i'm the afghanistan were uh it was an
extraordinary public uh and human rights
human um human rights exercise to
evacuate something like 15 000 people
to
every single one of them who landed in
the uk that night they were given
a home they were they were given a bed
they would give them food they were
absolutely looked after which just the
logistics of moving that many people at
once
over a two week period
i the logistics of that was quite
something to behold and then from then
um we have by the time i uh was um i
gave the roll up in january we had
housed something like 6 000 people over
six months that's the highest
resettlement rate of any program we've
ever had but it's really tricky because
you know we're not only talking about
bricks and mortar
it's the supply of the homes but also of
course getting children into school
making sure that
adults can speak english as as well as
they possibly can trying to help them
with jobs trying to help them with
access to health care and so on and also
the trauma of having been through what
they have been through so it was a
fascinating job
to do and it will continue to this day
but
yeah it
then ukraine came up and and clearly um
we all wanted to help with that and that
has taken some of the media attention
which i can understand
um now the final two questions i want to
ask you um
and you know
see how this goes but i wondered if you
would say i suppose
one thing you think perhaps you've
learned from boris johnson's premiership
or whether it's from the man himself or
just you know from the past few years
and then one thing you hopefully the
next leader might do differently
so with boris uh i think the fact that
with boris
an awful lot of people when they think
of boris a smile comes to their lips
and i think he bro he brings such a
joy de vivre if you like to political
life he has his own way of
communicating that clearly reaches
people
and he
has
an extraordinary resilience if you think
about it with the work that he's gone
through during covert being so terribly
ill with himself and so on
i think that for me has been
a real sort of
pleasure to watch um
and i very much hope that
we will be able to continue that as a
political party moving forward with the
new leader
with the new leader
i i think we
i think
we need to remind ourselves of the
difference between campaigning and
governing
um
we were very good at campaigning but
that is a different skill from governing
and
uh i very much hope that the next pm
will
have that uppermost in their mind not
least because
we can't you know this 24 7 news
channel uh real twitter and so on
we can't react to every headline we just
can't we've got to have our sort of
fundamental values and
strategies and principles running
through the government and that is what
we've got to stick to as part of our
governing of the country it's an
extraordinary privilege to be able to do
that and you've actually taken borrowers
johnson at pmq's saying twitter should
not be the main focus but yeah you've
taken that approach quite literally
and i found out the other day somebody
told me i'm the first person to have
resigned on instagram i mean who knew
there we go
yeah much more glamorous yeah
did you put a filter on it or
no no we had to we um
i had we had we couldn't fit it on the
photo so we cut off the
uh the lovely letterhead at the top and
anyway so it wasn't visually as perfect
as i would like but you know you've got
to get you've got to do it you've got to
get it congratulations on making history
thank you victoria for joining us
[Music]
you